[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by Spectators TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 30th of
November I'm James heel the spectator's
political correspondent and your host
for this week's episode coming up on the
show richek has played his part in a
diplomatic rout over the Elgen marbles
not everyone in Westminster agrees with
him though I'll be joined by Katy bulls
and Steven Bush of the financial
times as immigration figures continue to
rise here and elsewhere at an alarming
rate are government's capable of
stopping them but choosing not to do so
Lionel shrier joins me with demographer
and author Jennifer D scuber syu has
written about China's green agenda for
the cover piece this week as countries
meet in Dubai for cop 28 is z jingping
leading the world's green future Cindy
joins me on the show along with former
head of the CBI Tony Daner a photo has
gone viral online line of a multifaith
prayer room Ed outside Bristol
International Airport Reverend Marcus
Walker has railed against these rooms
for the magazine he joins me on the show
and lastly this week saw Revelations
about the royal family in obit scope's
book endgame the book was mysteriously
removed from Dutch bookshops the minute
it was released Alexander lman has the
story before we get going subscribe to
The Spectator and our flash sale and
you'll not only get your first 12 weeks
imprint and online for £12 but you'll
also get a bottle of Johnny Walker Black
Label whiskey absolutely free to claim
this offer go to www.sp spectator. co.uk
Whiskey it's only available within the
UK and of course you must be 18 or
over and a big thank you to our sponsors
cancord genuity wealth management
cancord are experienced wealth planners
and investment managers who offer
unwavering support during challenging
times to find out more visit CW
wealth.com for more
information first up richy C faced
criticism this week after counceling his
meeting with the Greek Prime Minister
are the Elgen marbles a sign of bigger
problems to come joining me now is
Steven bush from the financial times and
of course the spectators ktie Bulls now
Katie I think one of the RS that's been
dominating Westminster this week is
perhaps about a topic we didn't expect
which is the Elgen marbles tell us how
we got here and um what's number 10
thinking in all this yeah as you say I
think we were predicting the week ahead
and actually I did predict the week
ahead on Westminster hour um you know
when you say here at a big events coming
up and we did not have Elgen marbles
anywhere there so clearly that was
messed up um rishy C was meant to meet
with a Greek Prime Minister on
Monday that meeting was then cancelled
hours before it took place uh The reason
an interview he had given on Sunday to
the Laura cburg show in which the Greek
PR Minister had been asked by the algen
marbles and had ultimately uh you know
gone for it and said you know the
current situation of having someon the
UK and the rest in Athens is akin to
having half the Mona Lisa and the need
to be brought back together now of
course this has been long been The
Stance when it comes to the Greek
government's position on the El marbles
which had lots people say well he's just
said what everyone knows why has Russy
un canceled this meeting and uh because
Al the Greek side quickly you know
voiced their annoyance went quite public
with their concerns he had met K starma
before which you know could have soured
the mood um governing you know
governments never particularly like it
when uh the foreign counterparts meet
with the
opposition it turns out lots of theories
were going around as to why uh Rich was
so annoyed the official line is
effectively there is an agreement
between number 10 and the Greek
government that they would agree to the
meeting requested by the Greek
government but on the condition there
was not a public campaign or public
comments about the AL of marbles because
the UK position was not going to change
and I think AIDS were stung or at least
concern thinking back to 2021 when Boris
Johnson met with the Greek Prime
Minister and pre briefing uh you know
comments ahead of it too it just meant
that all the other issues were not you
know didn't get much coverage it became
a media Circus the problem is because
richy said I'm not going to do it and
instead did an hour meeting on the NHS
with officials nothing was discussed so
what he really wanted to talk about
boats and Gaza there was no you know
communication between the two sides and
therefore it's quite quickly led to
accusations that RX very brittle um he
you know labor is saying it shows he's
not serious um lab wanted to land this
idea he has a taty prime minister and so
you know he just threw his toys at the
pre the counter to this uh the other
Theory by the way is that this is a you
know a long-term strategy to start a
culture War by number 10 though I think
if you are looking for a culture war of
Mass Appeal for their target voters you
potentially wouldn't start with the Elan
marbles um you might go for something
else given I think polling suggests only
about 15% of the country really want the
AL marbles to stay here feel that
strongly about it I rich it was annoying
because he felt as though he had been
led up the Garden Path and agreement was
broken and also I think that he does
actually have quite strong views on the
eleg marbles Stephen was this a
mistake um it wasn't it wasn't so in a
in a way actually like the government
did have a positive news story um this
week right which was progress in ending
the NHS consultant strikes but actually
in some ways this story has been quite
convenient for both political parties
because the immigration statistics are
bad for the government um because
there's a chunk of their voters who are
very unhappy about it but they don't
want to have to raise taxes in order to
pay care workers more not to be
dependent on that you know that that
driver of those numbers and the labor
party kind of wants to be in a position
where it can attack the conservatives in
the on the abstract over that number but
without themselves getting tagged up
tagged with some kind of tens of
thousands Target that they know they're
not going to meet and in some ways
having a kind of row about isak TTI and
about the Elden
marbles served both parties purposes
pretty well this week I think however
look of course it's a mistake and I
think shows than the prime minister is
quite callow because ultimately like we
were always going to write about the
marbles they're the they're like the
sexy bit of the of the Anglo Greek
relationship but what every British
prime minister has basically done since
the return of democracy to Greece is sit
down have a you know have a polite not
on your Nelly and then talk about the
many many areas of agreement and I think
the problem with the public line on it
is it does make it seem like R doesn't
understand what the job of the Prime
Minister yeah involves um and that adds
to the thing that what is your strategic
Advantage when you're the incumbent PM
even when you're in the incumbent PM
where there's a you know global economic
pressures Local Economic pressures
pressure on the Public Services all of
which you're on the hook for politically
even though quite a lot of them aren't
really his fault um it's that you're the
Prime Minister already and I think then
by conceding any opportunity to remind
people you're the prime minister to you
know partly one of the things he does
poll better on is representing the UK
internationally I think it was a minor
misstep But ultimately like the big
problems facing the government are no
one can get a GP and the you know the
effective interest rates are working
their way through the mortgage market
and the consequence of the truss
experiment is then now people have
shifted from saying I accept then this
is a global problem to basically blaming
the government for all of the rising
interest rates even though to be honest
actually the truss effect has kind of
worked its way through the mortgage
market now I think if if if we can just
stick on the marbles briefly I think it
was interesting to obviously reveals
things about richy suck but it also we
do have a policy difference now on the
AL of marbles and now I appreciate this
is not going to be the issue that
decides the next election but K starma I
think partly for the reason Steven just
outl really trying to play up the fact
that he had this meeting because one
thing K St wants to do is show that he
can be a Statesman and therefore as many
of these meetings you see whenever you
know anyone the labor government meets
with someone from the Biden
Administration it's briefed out as if
it's this huge uh exciting moment and
there's no precedent at all for
opposition parties meeting it to give
the sense of momentum Liv in uh kid dama
met macron even though Ed Mand met orand
um when he was the leader of the
opposition so they want to take that
from it but when it comes to I think why
the Greek Prime Minister is warm towards
kir stama it's not just that he's 20
points ahead kir stama has suggested
that he supports um the AL marbles going
on loan uh or perhaps you know a mutual
loan if the British Museum and the Greek
government can agree to it you know
there's something George Osborne in his
role as head of the British museum wants
to do spoke about it recently whereas
rishy sunak just I think probably get
the context of why he actually seems to
have quite strong views on this does not
think and number 10 do not think the
Alan marbles should leave the UK even on
a me loan on the concern that actually
if there is a legal claim that's not
relinquished they won't get them back so
I think it does um you know there is a
light policy difference too when it
comes to why the Greek government will
probably prefer K dama to uh R given the
Greek Prime Minister made part of his
successful re-election campaign not the
main part but part was to renew efforts
to get the elen marbles back and Stephen
in your answer there you allude to the
fact that there is this kind continuing
to rout over migration I think some of
the comments that Robert jenrick made in
the house on uh Tuesday um have really
caught the eye um what's been going on
here and how much is there an extent of
a difference between um home office
ministers um and number 10 well it's
because Robert Jen was originally sort
of put in there essentially to be Ry
sonx
um eyes in the home office to be soel
Bran's minder almost but uh very rapidly
I think there was a feeling that you
know he he had perhaps integrated into
the community he was migrating into too
well and had kind of kind of become
sella Bran's voice eyes into Downing
Street um and I suspect so part of it is
and often departmental ministers
particularly when the departmental
ministers aren't that good at gripping a
department tend to go native what does
going native in a home office context
mean it means going well want that
number to go down and fighting with the
spending departments and the economic
departments for for more restrictions
and he essentially has been doing that
but also I suspect there's an element of
him feeling personally bruised that you
know he was seen as the deao Home
Secretary when that when he was first
appointed there's now another actual
Home Secretary called James cleverly
he's still not a full cabinet minister
he's actually the only one of rushi
sonak kind of you know the people who
kind of were you know bought into rishy
at mezanine level as it were who's not a
full cabinet minister and I suspect he
feels quite bruised about that ktie yeah
I think that's true in the sense Robert
J has been overlooked recently for Home
Secretary um also I think he's always
been someone who you know if you are in
that brief and Robert jenrick is also
seeing the fact that there you know the
strain in terms of places in hotels all
these things I think if you are in the
brief that he is in you're seeing up
close all the current problems with the
system we have and therefore I don't
think this is all uh you know put on
just to please the right of the party
but I think he is speaking more loudly
about it partly I think perhaps because
he has not got the job he wants but also
I think this just tends to happen which
is when a government's not doing
particularly well when I think um you
know people sense that their leader is
not in the strongest position they could
be it's not all about jostling for the
leadership per se but it does mean
people are more inclined and ministers
are more inclined to get their side of
the story out and perhaps you'll see
Collective discipline start to break
down yeah I mean I think in many ways
right the big picture story of politics
at the moment which is actually a rare
example where pmqs did tell you
something not because of who won or lost
the exchanges but it really was like one
of those late period Corbin pmqs when
Corin would stand up and there would
just be this wall of kind of Silence
from a parliamentary labor party like
yeah we don't think it's good we can't
do anything about it and you saw exactly
that dynamic in Reverse of that wall of
Silence behind the prime minister almost
and exactly as KY says when there's that
sense that the leader is weak um
everyone starts to act out a bit um and
once you've kind of lost that you kind
of need I mean the irony is is if you
know if if the conservatives hold to
hold Wellingborough by 10 votes then
suddenly the whole mood will transform
even though that would be pretty insane
but they kind of need something like
that I think to change the mood around
the Prime Minister thank you Stephen and
thank you
KY is immigration a problem that
politicians are choosing to avoid that's
what R shriber thinks who has written
about the figures for her magazine
column this week she joins me now along
with demographer and author of the 8
billion Jennifer d
scuber l I'll start with you first uh
you write in this week's magazine about
last week's uh net migration figures and
a certain sense of fatalism from the
public towards them explain your
argument as you set out in this week's
spectator well if you look at the polls
in both the United States and the UK uh
there's a lot of popular pressure for
reduced immigration that it's going it's
too much too fast and nobody asked the
people who actually live in these
countries uh whether they were
interested in a mass redesign of their
population um and yet there seemed to be
no political parties of uh big enough to
matter uh who are seriously devoted to
uh clamping down on the quantity and the
rapidity of uh incomers in both our
countries and uh it's it it makes people
angry uh but it also uh makes them feel
impotent and I I'm afraid that in this
column I confess to the fact that I have
become uh unhealthily addicted to
reading the comments after articles
about immigration in a whole range of
papers and one of the most interesting
things about that sampling is that the
same rage plus
impotence uh in these comments is not
only where you would expect them in the
telegraph you know or The Spectator um
but uh and in the Wall Street Journal of
course but even in the New York Times
and that's shocking and New Yorkers have
had a real taste of uh immigration
closeup because because New York is now
inundated with uh what New York thinks
is a lot of immigrants and what the
Border communities think is a drop in
the
bucket uh Jennifer I mean you know
there's no doubt these figures that came
out last week and the last two years
have been you extraordinary numbers for
the UK to take you know 700,000 600,000
or so what do you make of Lionel's peace
and what's your attitude generally to
mass migration of the kind we've seen in
recent
years yeah it you know the thing about
these liberal democracies that we live
in and liberal meaning just you know
we're supposed to be giving people the
the right to speak up here is that we
are not going to see any big change in
Immigration policy because there's
pressures on both the right and the left
for openness and there's pressures on
both the right and the left for closure
so I think the heart of Lionel's piece
saying we're stuck and we're not seeing
any change the politicians are stuck the
people are stuck it is absolutely true
but it's baked in into the system and so
that's where as a political scientist
with that hat on I see that it's been
that way for decades and decades and it
will be that way in the future a lot of
what I do is talk to businesses and
governments about you know what will the
future of demogra demographics be like
and what will the future of policy be
like and my answer with immigration is
it will be exactly the same because the
way these systems are designed it
doesn't allow for uh really rational
policy and in fact democracy itself
really encourages catering to Niche
interests and Catering to fear and
there's always a lot of fear around
demographic
change L I mean do you think that the
reasons politicians aren't addressing it
how much is it to do with sort of a lack
of uh initiative a lack of desire to to
talk about this I mean this morning I
was watching the home Affairs select
committee here in Westminster and it was
extraordinary that the fact that some of
the top civil servants for instance
didn't know the figures about how many
people were arriving being detained um
being deported Etc after Asylum claims
failed is it about a lack of iCal will
or is it simply we just don't have the
technical capabilities to follow on that
desire to try and stop the population
rise I I mean I I submit in my column
that uh most politicians don't know how
to stop immigration even if they wanted
to in a lot of instances they don't care
enough to want to but they're
fundamentally factless and uh you know
there are especially in the UK uh and
Europe generally huge legal barriers to
enforcing your own borders and they just
strike everyone is insurmountable and uh
it's like oh I'm sorry the the
helplessness that I detect in those
comment threads I also detect in
politicians they don't know what to do
they don't know how to do it it would be
hard and I'm I'm not sure I accept the
fatalistic position that this is just
going to keep happening and there's
nothing to do but in order to do
something it it would take enormous
political will it would take a lot of
political change it would in the UK it
would take a a complete transformation
of the Civil Service of the home office
which basically regards itself as you
know Britain's Open Door uh and and
that's that that's where that's where my
fatalism kicks in I don't see that
happening I I don't see politicians
really reversing themselves and making
the sacrifices and taking the political
risks that would be required to at least
narrow that open door there are
countries in the world who have very
strict immigration policies and uh
granted they take a demographic hit it
means that they have older populations
I'm you know talk about for example
Japan uh but it's worth it to them they
have decided that they would rather have
a shrinking population and a coherent
one uh rather than introduce the kind of
atomization and conflict that we have
accepted in the rest of the
West yes I mean Jennifer I mean Ral D
touches on the point about you know
social cohesion and that seems to be a
real sort of the real number of the
issue here which is that people feel as
though perhaps immigration is being
something done to them and their
communities are there any kind of policy
solutions for policy makers to look at
when doing this and and is there a
possibility of the case that as LEL says
you know migration is an issue certainly
of increased political salience here is
there a way of making perhaps
immigration more popular Mass
immigration more popular among um in
countries which are experiencing a lot
of it uh if it's a matter of you know
better policy Solutions or will people
always be hostile to large numbers of
people arriving uh if there's a sense
perhaps that the not being catered
to yeah I think the problem that all the
politicians take is that they're looking
for big splashy reforms and those will
never pass and and that's the case
across many policy areas we see it I
talk a lot about retirement policies
it's you know big things like macron
trying to raise retirement age to
actually make an impact you don't have
to do the big things that will never
pass you do smaller things but the
smaller things are not sexy and you're
not rewarded for that with votes uh
there are so many ways to ease the
perception of quote unquote takeover by
immigration because honestly at the end
of the day the numbers are interesting
but it's perception that matters the
most it's how you feel and you you know
I remember 20 years ago looking at some
of the the numbers of migration into
Europe that were much smaller that but
the perception and the feeling and the
rhetoric and the debate sounded exactly
the same so we you have to start moving
into nitty-gritty policies like do you
have enough resources in local schools
to help with uh non-english-speaking
students who are being put into
classrooms so that the community feels
like their children are supported and
the new incomer children are supported
as well well nobody wants to run on that
platform that's boring you want to do
something that really tries to you know
cater to specific voting groups so yes
there are so many policies that can be
done in the US our Asylum adjudication
system is incredibly underfunded and
understaffed well that's a boring thing
for a politician to talk about fixing
even though you would think both the
left and the right would have a vested
interest in fixing that system so I
think we're really stuck until we have
politicians who are not putting first
their own reelection and instead are
thinking about how to actually make the
system work for
everyone l i was wanted to ask you I
mean you obviously in your column talk
mostly about that kind of shared sense
of fatalism and particularly between uh
the UK and the us but I just wondered in
terms of the immigration debate and mass
migration what are the differences
between the two countries in terms of
you know obviously there's you the issue
around you the UK being an island as
opposed to having a large land mass with
Mexico for instance but what do you see
are the kind of similarities and
contrast between the two Nations and
their migration
approach well one of the big differences
is uh religion because uh and and that's
a another spanner in the works
emotionally and culturally uh because
the UK has a much higher immigration
rate of of of Muslims uh whereas in the
US basically they're coming from
everywhere uh but especially from Latin
America increasingly from India and even
from China uh the Chinese are coming up
through the southern border which
is really
surprising um China's a long way away um
I would say they share
the same fecklessness a complete
operational
failure uh and and also they share a a
political relationship to immigration
because uh you know the so-called Elite
is very big on
multiculturalism and um and basically
believes in open borders W which is not
the case with the population so you've
you've got uh people in charge who are
completely at odds with the with their
with their populace and at the same time
um you you've got massive operational
failure uh in inability to deal with the
numbers um and I guess the biggest
contrast between the two is that in the
UK the the problem if you look at as it
as a problem is legal immigration and
whereas in the US it's mostly illegal
immigration and to the tune of of
millions of people per year um the the
Biden Administration has probably led in
about eight million people and that is
uh even in a in a nation of
330 million people that's that's
starting to change the nature of your
population in a tiny period of time
there's another difference if May if I
may with the the us as well just to add
on to that and that's our two-party
system because even though you might
have segments of the population that are
are very um upset about the current
immigration levels or the nature of that
immigration the way the system is right
now the levels and numbers it works for
the politicians they do not face a
penalty for what is happening and that's
because we just have these two big
groups so when we look at polls yes
people might as as lonel mentions in her
column people might say that they want
lower immigration but when you start
asking them to rank the issues that they
care the most about you start asking
them about the salience of that issue
for them and what really gets them to
turn up to vote immigration starts to
move down the list so that means nobody
has to actually do anything there's a
there'll be a lot of talk about it in
all of the debates it'll be all over the
media but they won't actually face an
electoral penalty for doing nothing uh
some political scientists have called it
talk tough and do nothing because you
don't have to and so that's where we
start to see some really big differences
between uh the United States two-party
system and then some of the Continental
European systems that have multiple
parties and that's why you see some of
those parties starting to gain more
electoral victories on an
anti-immigration platform and that is
because there are more of them to choose
from I'd say there there is also one
other big difference and that's Trump
right the UK doesn't have a trump and um
you know the the immigration is moving
up voters list of concerns I know in the
UK it's now number three and that's
counting everybody including all those
labor voters and green voters it still
gets to number three uh and uh I don't
actually know the rankings for the us
right now but it is a huge factor in
Trump's popularity and he is the only
politician who is appreciably talking
about uh Mass immigration and wanting to
stop it and by the way I say this as
someone who does not support Trump never
has and dreads another Trump presidency
but those pictures of the Border these
tens of thousands of people moving
across uh shallow areas of the Rio Grand
being received by the border control
being put into buses and shipped all
over the country with virtually no
paperwork and and theoretical
appointments with immigration judges
literally years from now those pictures
are politically
Dynamite thank you Jennifer and thank
you
Lionel for the cover piece this week
cindu looks at how the Chinese Communist
Party spotted the business opportunity
in the green industry long ago China now
covers more than three4 of the world's
solar panels while a third of electric
vehicles sold in Britain are made in
China CH is this the start of China's
green era Cindy U joins me now to
discuss along with Tony Daner former
head of the
CBI um Cindy you write in this week's uh
magazine about China's green plans and
how it ties in with their economic
Ambitions tell us more about this yeah
so um China has basically spotted an
economic opportunity here in the global
drive for Renewables um the developed W
has been getting more and more climate
guilt over the last you know 10 15 20
years um and China you know it is a was
largest polluter but it's also the
factory of the world as well so what
happened was as soon as um as earli as
20 2005 really China's been looking into
Renewables as an export opportunity it's
really wanting to move on from the three
things that underpinned its economy
before which is clothing home
electronics and furniture and going into
much more high-tech Green Tech stuff and
this is great you know this is a great
business opportunity because the world
is only demanding more of these things
not less um and what's amazing is you
know as ever is the case with China when
they set their mind to do something the
industry just moved so incredibly fast
uh that we're now looking at basically
real domination of various Renewables
industries from EES to lithium batteries
to solar power to wind power all of
these things at the same time the West
is not supporting its own businesses in
competing with China on these as much as
the Chinese government is so you see
this kind of imbalance going on Tony has
the West been left behind on this and
specifically how is Britain fairing at a
time when for instance you know the
American government have the inflation
reduction act for instance is there a
danger that Britain is particularly left
behind in the race for Renewables yes
absolutely and uh Cindy described it
absolutely correctly you know by my
numbers I think Chinese green stimulus
is double the inflation reduction act in
the US is four times the EU stimulus and
I know that in British politics we're
criticizing the labor party for wanting
to spend 28 billion pounds on green
stimulus that would be a 40th of China
so we are left as a country
uh really once quite ahead on a lot of
areas of Green Technology of green
industry suddenly finding ourselves
completely outgunned by the rest of the
world and do you think perhaps there's a
chance then that the Net Zero agenda can
become an issue of National Security and
all this and actually that we we've seen
some powers in terms of uh the National
Security Act and Industry act do you
think that should be extended in terms
of these spares and government should
play much more of a role in order to try
and catch up with what the Chinese are
aheading of us on oh I worry about that
I worry about that I want to go straight
to the wedge issue for spectator
audience right which is a a skepticism a
hawkishness towards China but at the end
of the day this is about markets right
and in a way EVS are just the latest of
yet another manufactured good at which
China can dominate the world for all
kinds of reasons and as you say you know
the argument against the Chinese sort of
dominating the EV Market is either one
of well their subsidies are too high but
to be honest this is a sector that
everybody's subsidizing even us in the
UK are subsidizing this Market or we're
going to claim it's a national security
issue and I think we just need to be
careful about that one right you will
know much more than me about the China
issue and how the UK needs to confront
China in the new world I think it's a
stretch to say that them owning our EVS
is a big national security threat there
are clearly some strategic Industries we
need to be careful about I just don't
think the cars on our street are one of
them uh Cindy um Tony there talks about
you know markets and I wondered how much
is this about kind of you know Beijing
top down order State Control since 2005
or has this just been something that's
organic and responding to kind of
changes you know in the west rather than
any kind of central dictat you know what
it was it was China in a way that it
does throwing a lot of money at things
and just seeing what sticks right so in
2015 it has this industrial policy
called uh made in China 2025 which is
basically giving itself a 10-year window
in which to really excel at the
high-tech industries of the future
semiconductors robotics Aerospace
Renewables as well and it's just chucked
lots of money at all of these sectors
and Renewables has been the biggest
success story from this not so much
semiconductors and not so much robotics
all of these other things um and so that
this is we're looking back now and
thinking oh my God how do they do that
actually they they bet on a lot of
horses um and when it comes to you know
the Net Zero agenda you know I think
there will be an interpretation of the
story which is that oh China's been
egging us on to go to Net Zero just so
that we would buy their goods it's not
so much that it's that it's been clear
for quite a long time that this is what
the world where the world needed to go
in tackling climate change it's been
clear it's been clear to the West as
well I mean we've been driving this kind
of climate targets what we haven't been
doing is driving the industry that would
be providing these Goods so the UK is
the world's second largest installer of
offshore wind but we don't have a wind
manufacturing industry in this country
to speak of so why don't we so it's that
kind of in congruity that China doesn't
really have because it's just you know
thinking about all of these things as
business opportunities very
strategically and then Tony's point
about the security concerns I mean I
think let's see how much just in 10 15
years they really dominate EV market
right I mean it is technically possible
for an electric vehicle to be switched
off by manufacturer remotely right so
let's say two-thirds of British cars on
EES on the roads are Chinese in 20 years
if they all on mass shut down clearly
that's a security risk but there are so
many other ifs involved in that could
the Chinese company will it will it
really do that considering that would be
pretty much suicide for that company to
be kind of killing its customers uh will
the Chinese Communist Party really
demand that of a company um all of these
different things I think there are a lot
of ifs here but when we talk about
National Security in this kind of
fevered era that we're in at the moment
it's a lot about as but what is the
potential for something to go wrong what
is the potential for something to happen
and you know it's technically possible
but will it really happen and that's the
that's the analysis that you know policy
makers have to make
tny well look I think what this whole
thing poses a real question about is can
the UK compete in a green Industrial
Revolution that is mostly made
affordable by big countries in the world
through subsidy and we have a government
right now that doesn't want to
participate in subsidy although by the
way we'll throw in a little bit for
Nissan the other week and a little bit
for you know BMW uh and mini uh a few
months ago so I think the government's a
little bit confused about what their
stance really is but this is a
government that doesn't want to compete
with the inflation reduction act in the
US or with the the Chinese or the
European stimulus and I understand why I
understand the principles behind why but
let's be clear it means you lose right
and then we have a labor party who want
to invest uh you know what we regard as
a pretty big amount but even that isn't
going to be sufficient and so I think
Britain needs a more thoughtful and a
smarter Net Zero strategy than we've had
so far you know we've gone from Boris
Johnson's 10-point plan which I kind of
loved actually Boris doesn't get enough
credit for being an absolute green
believer
but it was a you know it was an
unprioritized strategy we're going to
have more of everything every form of
you know low carbon energy we're going
to have all these kind of product
markets like Eevee to a rishy sunak
strategy which seems to be Retreat and
of course the truth has to be somewhere
in between Britain is going to have to
work out what are our bets in the green
economy we don't have a lot of stimulus
right we don't have a lot of uh we do
actually have quite a few advantages and
things as you said like wind and we do
have someon EVS so let's have a strategy
that places some bets rather than being
subscale in everything in a world where
scale matters yeah absolutely and um for
my piece I spoke to um Adam Burman who
is at energy UK one of the industry
groups um involved in talking to these
energy companies in the UK and his idea
was basically talking about these nent
industries like hydrogen carbon capture
and storage with stuff that China hasn't
really and nobody in the world has
really kind of cracked because the
technology hasn't really existed just
yet so why don't we use the British R&D
specialities here and we should be that
would be a cheaper and more focused way
of doing these things rather than the
American or the Chinese way which has a
lot of wastage involved when it comes to
the money involved so I think we could
still respect back the lead it's just
that Richie sunak is not talking about
it all he's talking about is watering
Down The Net Zero Target or turning
pushing back the petrol car ban without
really talking about what he can be
doing for the EV companies in this
country so there there is still
inconsistency from the British approach
but maybe K will change that shortly
well I think whoever is in power right
we are subscale in what is a continental
sized economics right that's what green
markets have become Continental sized so
I think on all of these choices which
forms of energy offshore wind onshore
wind solar hydrogen which color hydrogen
I think Britain needs to take a very
simple Choice are we going to be
distinctive in this are we going to
genuinely lead the world are we going to
be competitive in this in other words we
need to kind of keep up but we're not
going to kid ourselves we'll be World
beating or do you know what is it okay
to buy them in is it okay to import
is it okay that China makes our electric
vehicles is it okay that China makes the
blades in our wind turbines maybe the
answer is yes I don't know what the
right answer is but no government's
going to have enough money in the UK to
make all these bets we're going to have
to choose I what have been the things
stopping us from making those choices I
mean obviously the question of money and
obviously money's type right now it's
the refrain I hear most in Westminster
and White Hall is you know there is no
money left so okay it's not just about
about resources um I don't particularly
think it's going to be a sort of an an
election issue in terms of the kind of
you know Green issues about investment
Etc what is it in terms of policy issues
that been stopping us from coming down
on the right the side whether it be
right or wrong Etc or coming down one
side of a total what are the kind of
things that you've seen in terms of uh
policy in initions in the last few years
and decade or so look I think it's just
an inability to choose right and maybe
I'm sorry to get a bit existential here
maybe that's about us coming to terms
with the size that we are and our
ability to compete in a world that's
incre inly Continental right maybe we'll
look back at this and saying it's a
Natural Choice that a country like us
needs to make post brexit we're not in a
big scale Market that therefore has
probably got the scale to play at
everything uh we're going to have to
choose our bets we're going to have to
be pluckier bolder braver and I think
when you look at the UK I mean there are
some areas where we have natural
Advantage you've spoken about some of
them right wind is the obvious one right
Pur Boris used to get mocked for saying
we should be the Saudi Arabia of wind
but of course he was right right wind is
an obvious area where the UK should
dominate there are definitely parts of
the EV value chain where we can Dominate
and lead the world particularly in R&D
the idea that we're going to compete on
assembly cheap assembly of electric
vehicle uh cars right is a hard one but
we probably do have to be competitive in
it we do have to have some kind of
presence and in the end like every
market right uh something being cheap is
one reason to buy it but something being
better quality better brand better
design better style I mean that's the
way the car markets always worked um
James so one of the companies that I
looked at uh that has failed in in
recent months is British Vault a British
startup which looked at um battery
making and it was going to be one of the
two gigafactories of making batteries in
the UK they went busted in January and
the former CEO has since then come out
and blamed you know to your to your
question blamed government instability
you know during the time over the last
over the last year when they were
struggling financially they had three
different prime ministers they have
numerous different secretaries of State
dealing with them on in different ways
um he directly pointed the finger of
blame at the treasury as well for not
releasing funding because of the
political instability so I think part of
it is just that we've had so many
leaders you know talk about Boris
Johnson's 10-point plan that was only
two years ago right and now we've got a
leader who's totally watering down Net
Zero so I think that is also a part of
it and maybe after the next election
things will stabilize a bit more but the
British political termoil can't be red
out I think we've focused mostly in this
discussion on Britain um Cindy but how's
it all gone down in China and recently
you wrote the piece about President Z
visiting America and trying to signal to
the West that you China is still open
for business um one element of this is
the economics there's also the domestic
polic seeks to consider and a more
prosperous middle class wanting to
ensure you have higher environmental
standards just talk us through that yeah
exactly so we often obviously see
stories through British lens
understandably but actually for China
this kind of export opportunity is also
about making sure that the country
becomes cleaner domestically as well and
this might sound crazy to people
watching at home because Beijing is so
polluted you know we know all about the
country's opening of new coal plants all
of these things are happening and it's
true but actually because of the growing
middle classes in China they're
demanding not necessarily political
rights so far but the right for their
children to breathe safe air to drink
safe water and the government um in the
last nine years have said that they've
announced the war on pollution basically
and the figures show that um
International observers have shown that
um Beijing air pollution is being hard
in the last 10 years uh that there are
hundreds of millions more people with
access to Safe Drinking Water because
the rivers have been cleaned up so what
we've seen in China is a huge Industrial
Revolution uh a huge scale of Industrial
Revolution and really fast pace uh over
the reform era but now as people get
richer and as economy slows down they're
demanding more things like just
Environmental Conservation just being
able to have access to Safe air and
water and the government is trying to
give that to them because otherwise it
becomes a legitimacy problem for the CCP
as well you know air pollution was one
of the most controversial issues for a
lot of Chinese middle class people not
so much voting rights but that so so for
the Chinese Communist party they had to
do something about it and and that's why
we see their domestic market for
Renewables is also huge you know Chinese
people are buying EES on mass as well so
I think that's fascinating to think
about this kind of coal uh guzzling
country also becoming the green uh the
engine of the Green Revolution globally
you know a lot of people will say uh
this is hypocrisy on the part of the
Chinese to be sort of pushing EVS our
way and dominating markets while
simultaneously investing in Coal I mean
I think every economy in the world is
guilty of such hypocrisy right now right
and it's not really hypocrisy it's
trying to manage this transition one of
the interesting UK political points that
hits this discussion is rishy sunak
choosing to ban H sorry to push back the
ban uh on uh on traditional cars and
sort of postpone that idea of everybody
switching to EVS you know that was done
for electoral purposes but it has had a
knock on consequence on the economic
viability of the EV market right the
truth was Britain was a highly
competitive destination for electric
vehicle manufacturing assembly R&D
battery production because we had
basically said by 2030 this Market is go
and once you put that back for political
reasons and if if we have an election
where actually we're going to have
parties trying to use green deadlines
green targets is a political football
because they think the voters like it
that will have an economic consequence
right pushing back by 5 years right the
deadline for everybody switching to EVS
pushes back the development of the
market makes Britain a little less
competitive so there is a risk in an
election year if we want to try and row
back if the conservatives want to row
back from Green pledges in order to win
votes there is an economic KnockOn
effect in a market where we're already
struggling to compete so that's my
little pitch for keeping up green
targets not because I'm trying to be
some green campaigner but because that's
the way one of the ways in which we can
compete economically with people who are
much bigger than us thank you Cindy and
thank you
Tony you may have seen an image go viral
this week of a strange pod built outside
Bristol International Airport that's a
multifaith prayer room which has since
been ridiculed by many online Reverend
Marcus Walker is with me now to
discuss hello Marcus I think you've
written probably my favorite feature in
this week's magazine uh about uh
multifaith prayer rooms and it's amazing
how something so ugly could Inspire
something so beautiful in your feature
this week um you've written specifically
about this new Infamous viral uh
multifaith prayer room that's just been
erected outside uh Bristol International
Airport could you just tell us a bit
about this and what inspired you to
write this week's
feature well Bristol airport decided to
unleash this uh multifaith area through
the medium of Twitter earlier this week
and it well I mean I think it's safe to
say that it immediately became the a
viral tweet it was you know their
enthusiasm for announcing that this
multifaith prayer area had been opened
on the side of the silverfield
roundabout in the free waiting zone of
the airport was not matched by the
photographs which well just looked so
insultingly pathetic it was I mean at
first I actually thought it was a prank
um it's essentially a bu stop um a
particularly ugly bus stop um made of of
plastic and perspect glass it's um it's
got walls that don't quite get down to
the floor probably to make sure the
homeless can't sleep in there because we
all know that if there's one thing that
people of Faith really don't like it's a
homeless or the poor being among
them um it's I mean it almost perfectly
sums up the the contempt with which so
many people in officialdom actually hold
um religion
in yeah I mean I think more seriously
you do write in your piece this week
about the dangers of trying to appeal to
lowest common denominator and effect
trying to please everyone you please no
one is this something that we're seeing
more of not just in you know the Church
of England but also I think probably all
walks of life as well absolutely um and
actually it's insulting to people of all
faith mean broadly speaking this is the
kind of prayer room only a person of no
faith could
create all faiths Hindu um Muslims
Buddhists Christians of every different
shape and size have found ways
to ensure that their spaces of prayer
are ones which enhance the soul and
enhance the mind and draw the Mind
towards the
Divine um the greatest art in the
history of mankind has been uh created
in order to
exalt uh God and draw the human mind to
God so the idea that well you know just
stick them in an empty room ideally
above about shelter on the side of a
roundabout and they'll just be happy is
something only somebody of no faith
could conceivably have and it insults
you know it insults Muslims it insults
Jews it insults Hindus it insults
Buddhists it insults Christians it
insults everybody really um and the
general defense is you know well of
course you can worship God anywhere you
know you don't need anything in
particular um and well I mean I you know
to an extent that's true but in the
end there is a reason there is a
psychological reason why Beauty enhances
worship and enhances prayer and there's
a psychological reason why every faith
has always tried um to use Beauty to
this
effect yes and I think you're writing
the piece as well about prayer and of
course you know some of the most devout
prayer comes in some of the most
difficult of circumstances we can all
think of famous examples in culture and
history in contemporary day Christianity
just to give a few examples but as you
say just because you know in necessity
you can pray somewhere doesn't mean it
should be in the most barren inspiring
and frankly as you put it you know the
piece sort of irreligious environments
just like this this this glorified um
prayer room um I just wondered as a
result of what you know you've seen on
Twitter Etc do you think there is a bit
of a backlash and do you think that some
of this kind of you know soulless style
uh public places there could be a
reaction to that well I hope so I mean I
hope that in public places we might
actually start to think a lot more
deeply about what people need
particularly in places like airports
where an awful lot of people are
frightened
um if disaster strikes as you know
tragically from time to time it does all
around the world it's a place where
people are going to turn um in their
deepest distress or fear actually to
start asking what's needed and the
reality is different faiths probably
need different spaces with different
things we actually need to recognize
that different people will find
different ways of being enhanced to the
divine although actually just any form
of beauty can be used as a great as a
great tool and we might just be able to
identify what ways might
enhance um people's Soul um and and and
and actually start start properly
putting our thinking caps on rather than
just making a dultery
tokenistic gesture like
this I mean how long have these
multifaith programs been been put up for
I mean it seems to be a relatively
recent phenomena
how how does this one compare to any
others you have seen or visited uh Mark
I suspect you're not a regular to many
of these multifaith prayer rooms but um
just wondered if you give us a bit of
context to the one that's just been
erected at
Bristol no I suppose I'm not well it
depends really what you mean though that
you when you visit when I visit people
in hospital very much depends which
hospital you're going to as to what the
the provision um is like um thinking
about the hospital right next door
actually one of the places of prayer is
actually a a church it's a church run by
us and bolom the less I'm in the parish
is great St bartholomy we have a big
church the great and a little church the
less and the less is inside the hospital
and it's Christian it's Anglican and
it's filled with the imageries that we
find helpful and it is never empty never
at any moment of the day is it empty
there are always people in there
lighting candles praying kneeling giving
thanks crying crying in fear crying in
sadness Crying In Joy um but you can see
that it's
a the visual signs are hugely important
there are also other prayer spaces for
other people of other faiths around the
hospital and that works very well too
but you know whenever I've been to an
airport uh multifaith prayer space or to
our Hospital multifaith prayer space I
mean if I'm honest in a hospital I'd
rather Pray by somebody's bed where
There's real necessity than in just a a
blank space um in an airport you know
I'd rather whip out my prayer book and
pray you know just sitting on a bench
than just be in this sort of sterile
arid environment I almost think it's a
hindrance to prayer you know and I think
it's awfully
sad yes I mean you're describing the
piece about it being almost tokenistic
you know we need a multifaith pray room
box ticked so actually I think you know
what you're saying there is just it's
it's not even any kind of you know not
even a faith or lack of faith Etc just
purely as a matter of sort of formality
and bureaucracy rather than any kind of
proper thinking or feeling and also I
mean I would say it almost I have to say
when when just trying to get into the
space for
prayer um I could pray much better in
say the Blue Mosque in uh in
Istanbul um and have prayed with those
wonderful windows in the um hadassa
Hospital
in Jerusalem and hope one day with the
world calms to be able to go to the omad
mosque in in Damascus so places of great
Beauty where I can personally connect
with the Divine where I can feel that
Souls have been
uplifted um I'm not you know I'm not
saying every single Chapel needs to be a
Christian and ideally an Anglican sort
of one actually it's about recognizing
that
beauty is important and beauty is
important for people of of
religions across the
world quite and as you say you know the
beauty of all different faiths has
inspired so many who are not of those
faiths as well um um Marcus thank you so
much for joining us on spec TV really
appreciate you giving us your
time thank
you and finally what royal Revelations
appeared in obit sco's endgame that led
to the book being quickly removed from
the shops on the day of its release
Alexander lman joins me now with the
story alander thanks for joining
spectator TV uh the Royal has been back
in the news this week with the release
of Royal correspondent omed sc's new
book uh it quickly had to be removed
from the bookshelves in the Netherlands
tell us what happened there well the
trouble is James is that as luck would
have it there was this translation of
omed scobby and I think calling him a
royal correspondence putting it a bit
strongly his new uh book end game came
out and what's very interesting is that
in the English version Omid as we must
call him reveals that there are two
members of the royal family who were the
racist Royals who apparently when the
when Megan was pregnant with her first
child by Prince Harry asked what skin
color the baby was likely to be now Omid
claims that he knows who these people
are but he can't possibly say who they
are because of UK
laws but obviously in Holland you don't
have UK laws so as luck would have it
this translation that has appeared has
the names of the two people involved so
what's happened is that the you is that
the Dutch publisher has pulled these
titles off the shelves and said oh no we
couldn't possibly have meant to say that
but of course all the proof copies have
already gone out to all the editors and
reviewers and bloggers so every single
person in a position of public influence
in Holland who've been sent a copy of a
book will now know the identities of
these two people and it's it's hilarious
because scobby gave an interview to
Dutch television in which he said well
my version of the book doesn't have any
of this information in it you're
thinking what mean your version of a
book I mean are there about 10 different
versions would exist whereby your
version is just one of them and it's
it's hilarious really because you can
imagine this with that idea that you
know Camp Sussex has a dozen people out
there just like scop and that he's a
sort of not so much one person there's
about 10 of them so I mean all
lightheartedness aside what you have to
see is that there's clearly something
happening from Camp Sussex and that I
mean Megan especially has been quite
quiet this year because Harry had spare
he's had all the publicity around that
and he's had
invictor but I mean all we've really
heard about her is this stuff about will
she be making a cameo in the last season
of suits and stuff like that and I think
one thing we've seen over the last half
decade is that Megan Markle is not a
woman who doesn't like publicity so what
you start to think to yourself is is she
going to be doing something via
intermediaries which is going to get her
side of the story back out there and
obviously the biggest detail from the
APR winrey interview that she inh hared
in 2021 Wass a hint about the idea of
his racist member of the royal family
and the fact that scobby has put this
detail into the book with this added
bonus name means that we to wonder well
how exactly has some translator in
Holland
decided I know I'm going to create the
biggest Royal news story of the year for
fun and it I mean none of it's adding up
and a lot of what's going on means that
they're treating you me and the average
person on the street like idiots I think
what we have to be asking is there is an
agenda and whose agenda is it it and
what exactly is going on well talk about
you know speaking your Truth uh giving
one-sided accounts um what are the other
main claims in this new book obviously
the racist worldy one is that's
dominates the headlines but I just
wondered from what we've heard and seen
so far are we expecting more of those
kind of Revelations or is it sort of a
one headline fact story what what what
was interesting for me is when I saw the
first stories of the book I thought
there's nothing new here I mean oh
Prince William wants to be king oh
Princess Kate is quite amable and she's
quite tame compared to Megan and Diana
oh you know there are tensions between
William and Harry like I just kept
thinking everybody knows all this stuff
I mean literally nothing that I saw the
first weekends Revelations was of the
slightest surprise to me and I think
with what scobby and his Publishers may
have done is a kind of dead cat strategy
because finding Freedom which is a Rish
book which scobby wrote a few years ago
about Harry and Megan escaping from the
cruel confins of a raw family it was a
massive bestseller because what we're
not used to in this country is the idea
that we we write books about the royal
family which are not hagiographies which
are just straightforward M green gossip
and I think that the fact that the book
was very critical for the RO family and
also very very flattering about Harry
and Megan meant there was a market to
that and so the Publishers have decided
that um game which I thought would have
nothing to do with the Becket play but
scobby quotes the Becket play at the end
so you see he's an intellectual as well
as everything else which is really
really flattering I think that the
trouble that we now have is that I mean
what what's going to come with new and
you see ah if you name the racist
members of the raw family the Dutch
translation of a book so that it
helpfully goes viral the week of
publication so that when it eventually
comes out it gives you all the credit
and all the story that you couldn't have
put in for you I mean it's it's it's
clever it's cynical and it's mellian but
it's clever and I just don't know who
it's coming from is it coming from his
publicists in which because you know
give all the Rays is it coming from
scobby in which case give him a
Knighthood or as is more likely is it
coming from this couple who have you
know a huge amount of power I mean
they've they've got deals with these I
mean the deals are slowly dwindling away
because nobody watched the Netflix
series nobody listened to the Apple
podcasts or Spotify podcasts but
nonetheless you're talking about a huge
amount of influence and so I cannot
believe that any of this is coincidental
or accidental Yeah you mentioned there
in your your sort of answer there the
nature of diminishing returns and
frankly how much is there a public
appetite a few years ago of course there
was Finding freedom but having heard so
much from Harry and Megan and The Wider
Camp susex Etc about what went on during
the years they were active Royals I mean
is there now a sense perhaps that
interest has waned in all of this hence
why perhaps we're seeing now Megan and
Harry keeping a slightly more dignified
silence in the hope that they could be
remitted to the
fold I think dignified silence is
putting it a bit strongly I think it's
more you send in your attack dog and
you're standing on the side and you're
placing bets on what your attack Do's
going to do but no I think that question
that I have is that you know a couple of
weeks ago there was all this story brief
brief depress in great detail about the
reconciliation between Harry and King
Charles and then also the same breath
the idea that William and Harry there is
no reconciliation that who are forever
estranged and what I want to know I mean
I'm because I'm fascinated by all this I
mean I I literally your equiv of your
popcorn munching pter is what is going
to I mean quite literally what is the
the end game here
because I think Harry has done more
damage to the RO family than anybody
since Ed with the eight he probably done
more damage from NE as well because
least when he became J Windsor he just
packed him off Bahamas made him
irrelevant whereas Harry in California
he's still this figure of international
Fascination and I mean while I don't
think he's clever Megan is clever and
you can see that between the two of them
you are working towards this solution
which
I think is nothing less from the
demolition of the roal family as it
stands and in scobby they found a very
useful boswells of their Collective
Johnson who is very happy to give them
what they want and I think it's both
Sinister and also fascinating because
ultimately Republicans everywhere are
going to be rejoicing at endgame because
they're going to see this book as the
absolute Vindication what they've been
saying for years but for the rest of us
you just think to yourself well are the
Royal Family really that awful are they
really the David Ike incarnation of them
as you know cheese eating lizards or
whatever Ike says these days or are they
in fact flawed human beings who are
placed on the international stage and be
given far more scrutiny than any of us
would ever like and thus their flaws are
magnified far beyond what they actually
are Alexander thank you so much for
joining us on spectator TV
today that's it for this week once again
if you do enjoy spectator TV please
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss another episode I'd also
like to thank our sponsors canical
genuity wealth management can oford or
experienced wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support during challenging times visit
CW wealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next
[Music]
week